you got some [ __ ] body on you oh my
god [ __ ] hard for this goddamn right
you do it was the fat one and now I yeah
like you were the one everyone was
goofing on and that must have been
really bad for you growing up well my
entire life I've always been compared to
Kourtney and Kim they've always been hot
hot and even in your so-called awkward
phase they didn't I don't feel bad for
their awkward phase you started hitting
the gym obsessively right yeah what kind
of workouts were you doing in Dallas it
was a lot of cardio how long before you
got hot all of a sudden did you start
looking in the mirror at yourself naked
and going Jesus Christ my stomach's flat
my ass looks really hot no at first like
the whole time in Dallas I was like what
the [ __ ] all I'm doing is working out
nothing's happening it it takes a minute
to notice a change yes like six months
you are rip right now right are you in
the best shape of your life for sure
definitely I I agree I follow the
pictures you've never had boob job no
never had a boob job but I do want I do
want a boob job don't everyone says I
know but I'll tell you why I looked at
you naked on laying down flat you know
the shot I'm talking about okay right I
looked up on me yeah with the glitter I
want look at your boobs but I wear
push-up bras all the time like I wear
padded bras because I love the cleavage
when I don't want a bride don't have
cleavage I think I will get a boob job
for sure but then I could always remove
them how come I don't see nip I don't
know they're just not hard why are they
not hard you're around me I know who got
them hi Bobby's a basketball player you
probably [ __ ]